and that is Michael Rapaport who joins
us now on the Rich Eisen show how are
you sir I'm good my friend he doing I'm
doing well how'd it go how to feel last
week it's all great but I I don't know
maybe you didn't get the memo yes please
introduce me a senior fantasy football
analyst Michael rap but when you refer
to me please next time please a little
respect senior fantasy football analyst
Michael rabbi and I come on and I'm
sorry
give some information like you know like
older tickets asking me right off the
top but I'm happy to be here
it went fantastic on fantasy zone last
week we're gonna be there all season me
the Guru and Kay Adams we had a you know
very lackluster you know overall fantasy
football a weak one but but I'm
expecting a more action and more
excitement going into week two there
were some surprises in Week one there
were some breakouts in week one and you
know I'm I'm glad that we're past week
to be honest well you know I'm sorry
about the name thing I and and it's as
if you read my mind I always at NFL
Network when I'm with Michael Fabiano
before like we'll be in a commercial
we'll be like 30 seconds 10 seconds back
to air and I look at him and I go what
am I supposed to call you again what's
your - like like it changes everything
like was it fantasy senior expert
insider guru he's actually Fabiano is
Michael Rapaport a fantasy Hall of Famer
there is there is like a Hall of Fame in
someone's basement somewhere for for
fantasy football analyst so I mean you
could get a gold jacket one day I'm
expecting two and I don't think it's in
any basement I heard allegedly
they are erecting the sports the fantasy
sports hall of fame somewhere in the
Midwest the location hasn't been
revealed but I heard from my sources
that they are erecting it you know but
in all seriousness I love fantasy
football I love doing the fantasy zone
you know and for me you know the thing
about the fantasy football that it's
done for me
um it just made me a bigger fan of the
NFL you know I think that you know
obviously fantasy isn't real football
but being a fantasy football fan and and
and and somehow plays in and someone who
loves it whether you're playing for high
stakes you know or Oreo cookies you know
like the landscape of what I know about
the NFL is is like it's ever been before
but just because you're following so
many players that are either on your
teams or on teams that you're going
against guys that you wanted to draft
guys that you didn't dress and and for
me you know as competitive as I am with
fantasy football it's really just so
much fun and it's just a fun way to to
watch the game and sort of a vessel into
the real football but I think they're
they're warning the same so so I'm
loving doing it and you know I'm glad
that the NFL is agreed to and hopefully
we could have a safe weekend and there
won't be you know so many key injuries
as there were in week one it was hard to
see you know guys go down so quickly um
but I'm ready for week two there's a lot
of good game and a lot of good fantasy
matchups I'm with you let's uh let's
talk about week to hear Michael Rapaport
fantasy zone 704 on Sunday the you do
you did a believe the hype don't believe
the hype thing last week so let's go
through the people for whom you are
believing the hype this week you believe
the Tyreke Hill hype this week I believe
that Tyreke Tilford this this week he's
got a good matchup he's gonna continue
to do his thing I I don't think that the
Philly uh the Philly secondary is gonna
be able to hold him I don't think
anybody could hold him you know he's on
a roll he's exciting and I think that
he's going to have a very good game and
realize and in fantasy this weekend if
you're playing daily fantasy football
and he's on your team I mean I'm not
giving them they're giving any breaking
news and then you also believe the hype
on Julio Jones you don't believe the
hype though this one's interesting you
don't believe the hype on on Dez Bryant
who got shut out last week by generous
Jenkins in Denver
against the no-fly zone I will be
shocked if Julio and the Atlanta Falcons
and everybody on the Green Bay Packers
and the names are you know the regular
is including a Martellus Bennett and and
and my man py Hilton and of course Aaron
Rodgers and everybody on Atlanta being a
Julio being the main do because he
didn't get the rock that much last week
I think that's gonna be the shoot out
the game and it's in primetime
I think there's going to be big numbers
and realized and big numbers and fantasy
and yes I predicted it on this year's
show last week and I'm predicting it
again Dez Bryant is going to be a no
show in Denver their defense has
historically been tough on him they are
they're gonna lock him down I don't
think you'll have any bit more than
three to four catches and I don't think
anything sensations like you know he's
Dez Bryant so he could always you could
always you know break something big but
I don't think I think going forward you
know week five six I don't think you
should trade Dez I don't think you
broken or busted but this isn't a good
matchup for him all Shawn Jeffrey Marcus
Peters is gonna give him the business
that's another person do not believe the
hype on all Sun and my main man Maddy
Stafford who did great last week despite
the fact that he almost gave me a in the
first quarter was that six six he turned
it around I have a soft spot for Maddy
Maddy Stafford uh he might be the new
Maddy ice he's going to have a problem
along with Golden Tate gala day and
every single thing that comes out of the
Detroit y receiving corps they're gonna
have a tough time
Maddy Stafford it's gonna as somebody
once said don't believe the hype it's a
sequel Michael Rapaport from the fantasy
zone on 704 coming up this week in week
two on NFL Sunday Ticket last thing have
you made any trades yet cuz I made a
trade actually this week and I almost
feel like we were talking before about
how you don't know anything after week
one in terms of teams in fantasy I feel
like it's almost the same way so I you
want to make a deal but you also don't
want to overreact because eventually
after 17 weeks these guys you drafted
high or you think are gonna come around
listen to me well why don't you call me
you got my nose you want to make a trade
after week one you just call me you an
athlete for mine but I I don't do it for
the money I do it for the honey you
wanna make a true what did you do I
traded I traded luck for rivers cuz I
don't think Luck's playing anytime soon
I needed another quarterback that's fine
it's not bad
Fabiano proposed that trade about
Fabiano this guy trees I mean Alice in
Chains week with him I am nuts me you
know I don't know if he's listening
there he's got a cousin or an assistant
I'm a senior fantasy football analyst I
have an assistant listen and it keeps
their ears to the street on anybody
that's talking about me but Fabiano this
guy this guy offers some really really
selfish straight I'm think it was early
in the season when you want to make a
blockbuster trade and you're ready to
make a big boy shake you know where to
find me don't come to me with any of
this nonsense he's trying to give me
like you know a bag of donuts a
newspaper and something else for Tom
Brady I'm gonna start giving you my pay
phone number man like a I'm like lose my
number Fabiano michael rapaport see him
sunday on 704 on the fantasy zone with
the Guru and with Kay Adams as well man
it's great to have you on team thanks
for coming on have a great weekend and
even though I love listening to rich but
where rich is doing something I don't
see sailing or calling the game
somewhere you're a great replacement
thank you sir he's sailing home from
Cincinnati on a catamaran I believe
Michael Rapaport
Wow everybody calling out Fabiano
Fabiano's a friend friend of the program
by the way yes correct to grapple bore
he's going a little bit over the top
there the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
isn't it amazing you can download an app
with your thumbprint you should download
our app with your thumbprint